foreign
guys it is day 59 of taking a nice bath
every single day
I gotta be real with you I feel like
putting
I don't want to do this today
[Music]
I stood there staring at the window
procrastinating for the last 20 minutes
thinking about all the excuses that I
had not to do this and then I thought to
myself if all those things stacked
against me what if I could still pull
this off water temperature is one degree
Celsius we're gonna do three minutes in
the ice bath no matter what's going on
in my mind right now it's still gonna be
a good day
[Music]
yeah
can you stay true to what you said you
were going to do see motivational get
you started but without discipline
you'll never finish all right time's up
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]